[Musique]
merci d'être avec nous bruno mérine
merci d'être là nous vous en prie
en plus on a un petit antilles en est on
connaît une perte nette de personnes en
commun tous les délivrer et oui mon père
au travers
eric mon père qui vous êtes vous êtes
vous un côté vous habite à côté tu mon
père mes voisins et paraître mon père
vous emmerde parce qu'il garde toujours
sa voiture sur un parking non mais là il
a un parking commun avec le avec le mien
bien d'accord ça va il m'ennuie pas du
tout bon c'est vrai il est sympa et très
discrète mais très discret travers de
son fils vous concernant merci beaucoup
d'être là alors comment se vit une
enfance quand on est le fils de l'ennemi
public numéro 1 il faut savoir que
chaque mairie c'est vraiment c'est le
plus grand gangster de toute l'histoire
de france voilà comment on dit est ce
qu'à l'école vos petits camarades savent
et qui vous écris des votes pas quand je
suis à trois heures non oui bah après on
va dire continent en prison à partir
d'un vallières à partir du moment que
qu'il ait connu est vraiment dans les
médias redire c'est les années 70 cela
je fais à peu à peu près huit ans là-bas
dans la cour de récréation les gens
jouent à mon père et moi je me retrouve
au milieu de mes camarades je peux pas
dire qui je suis souvent j'ai eu des
faux nom pour sa part facilement il y
avait que le directeur qui savait qui
j'étais en fait ouais mais qu'est ce que
vous répondez à vos petits camarades au
professeur quand ils essaient de savoir
ce que faisait votre papa ah ben moi
j'ai appris pendant des années à dire
que mon père était mort comme ça c'était
plus simple ah ouais saviez sam éviter
d'avoir des réponses alors après les
gens me demandaient de commandes était
mort et que les fêtards alors des fois
tu choisis ou pas plus de six vagues et
ça passait quoi mais se compliquer
le plus dur c'est à dire la vérité en
fait que quand on est le gamin comment
comment on vit son enfance quand son
papa est en cavale
comment vous voyez comment vous arrivez
à le voir comment vous n'avez pas parlé
comment tu vois arriver à le voir rob
sera dans mon livre mais non
stationnaire il n'y a pas beaucoup de
possibilités non plus un vrai produit
risque peut prôner à skis ski prenaient
des risques pour vous voir pour voir ses
enfants oui oui oui oui mais pas deux
fois deux fois mais cette fois il était
déguisé forcément comme moi je vais une
fois je l'avais pas reconnu et bien sûr
doit gare iv avait plus ou moins
dépanneur en fin de compte le dépanneur
c'était mon père
ouais ils étaient quelque el papa
jacques marinées ce qui vous disaient
qu'ils vous adorable ils vous disaient
qu'ils vous aimez quand vous venez au
parloir oui oui vous voyez vous avez
mais il le disait à sa manière un mets
moi moi il est extrêmement fier de moi
je sais pas pourquoi on vous dit que
vous étiez un enfant du rsa donc oui oui
vous voulez vous travaillez bien l'école
tout ça et vous dit comment tu
travailles le port lui fallait pas que
je fasse des bêtises
ouais il fallait que je sois un bon
petit fils parce que c'est sa mère kim
élevé il fallait que je sois un bon
gamin à l'école pour pas qu'on fasse
aucun reproche possible moi j'étais pas
non plus mais pas les s qui est-ce qui
est ce qu'il est arrivé de vous demandez
pas ce que vous aviez fait une bêtise il
m'a engueulé une seule fois pourquoi sam
une seule fois parce que fournisseur de
mobylettes j'allais avoir 14 ans donc là
l'âge d'avoir une mobylette
moi je vois du tout mes petits copains
en avoir une et caetera et à mon père un
coach aimerait bien en avoir une et c
est je sais pas pourquoi
ma soeur et lui avaient à peu monté la
tête etc et il signe à m'engueuler
haut-parleurs que jamais il m'avait
engueuler comme et dix minutes après je
le regarde un peu comme ça fait pas
grave ça me plaît que tu leur as quand
même voilà mais bon c'était un petit
toit c'est non mais moi c'est important
je m'étais jamais fait engueuler par un
pc c'est un échange
il vous faisait peur ou pas non non pas
du mendiant êtes fiers de votre père oui
oui oui c'est pas dans pas dans
l'excessif moi je suis moins fan que les
fans de mon père en fait c'est vrai
qu'il était très populaire mais mal et
j'ai aimé mais en ce moment c'est même
incroyable c'est sans fin le jour de son
assassinat
comment vous l'apprenez mais enfin final
il n'y a même pas eu ras de son poteau
il ya 27 ans de procédure pour obtenir
un non-lieu à la fin donc un policier
voilà qui étaient sur les lieux qui dit
on pouvait pas on est obligé de tirer
les gars je t'aime irin
c'était pas n'importe qui on a été
obligés de tirer
qu'est ce que vous dites à ça alors moi
je dis qu'avec enfermé dans une bmw
attachée à sa ceinture les deux mains
sur le volant
face à quatre tireurs d'élite qui sont à
3 mètres de lui avec des fusils d'assaut
de l'armée et avec une trentaine de
flics tout autour si mon père est encore
dangereux faut m'expliquer là là comment
vous l'avez appris j'ai appris moi
j'allais j'étais donc à l'abri dans mon
petit village de savoir et j'ai pour la
toussaint je vais sur la tombe de mon
grand père je suis sur la route avec ma
grand-mère ont heureusement ma grand
mère hannaë n'avait pas d'autoradio
donc on arrive on arrive on arrive à
clichy à l'appartement familial et dans
la rue des centaines des centaines de
personnes et qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce qui se passe voilà tout le
monde me saute dans les bras tempéré
mort tempérament voir ça décalage
j'avais va dire quinze ans parce que
j'avais 14 ans et erevan 21 quelques
jours quoi vous avez sa victime un saut
vous savez pris la nouvelle
robert dès que s'il est que j'ai appris
la nouvelle je montais tutelle
appartement trop laid mais la télévision
pour font venir mais je rêve où j'aurais
voulu
voilà
la police n'ont pas la police beaucoup
pas à parler en ce moment des violences
policières etc
c'est encore un autre sujet donc j'en
veux à broussard et sa petite bande de
gaza la commissaire broussard sur l'
enquête pendant des années des années
leurs voeux à ce mec là et à sa petite
bande qui ont reçu l'ordre de tuer mon
père y penser qu'il aura donné ordre de
tuer votre père je voulais pas mais j'y
retourne en prison
non mais c'est en en prison il va
refaire encore du spectacle au dernier
procès qu'il a fait tout le monde
applaudissait
non non il voulait plus d'un mec comme
lui parce que le danger pouvait de mon
père c'est ça qui l'a conduit quelque
part sa fin quand on devient un concert
populaire ça c'est pas bon ça
ben ouais c'est ça c'est parce qu'il
était très aimée mais les mêmes des
sondages sur lui pour sa part sur sa
popularité oui delphine alors justement
c'est lui l'homme de l'année par part
est malsaine marque parismatch arrêté 6e
et oui élu homme de l'année
on découvre ouais c'est ça crois oui
c'était votre papa donc vous l'aimiez
mais est-ce qu'un jour vous lui en avait
voulu des choix qu'il a fait dans sa vie
parce qu'au final il faut pas en vouloir
à la police ou quoi que ce soit c'est
ses propres choix
on est content si je dois en vouloir à
mon père que c'est face à szczesny de
cette manière là je serai pire des
[ __ ] de fisc mes choix non mesdames
mais il a tellement plus fort au prix au
prix fort puis je peux pas en vouloir à
mon père et ses passes possibles et est
populaire parce que surtout il avait un
engagement en politique
will est qu à chasser et d'ailleurs les
gens ne mesurent pas être dans la prison
c'était une prison dans la prison dans
une prison au moins ce qui m'a toujours
frappé avec vous ce que en fait il était
psychologiquement ils n'avaient pas
craqué parce que dans la chasse à broyer
les gens c'est sûr ça qui s'évade et 400
artistes sécurité c'est quand même le
premier motif de son évasion parce qu'il
est dit si je reste comme ça encore cinq
ans mais je serai brisé je serais cassé
et voilà il ya en plus une évasion comme
ça elle n'en a fait une plus fort au
canada
bruno télé payante dakar dans la cadre
de la 4 voies canada de laisser unité
spéciale de correction vous assurer que
c'est la villa sur les vélos 6 1
renault est ce que vous vous avez songé
un moment à faire la même carrière que
votre père
on y pense quinze ans quand on perd son
papa du jeune pilote d'hélicoptère de
france militaire on m'a dit à l'époque
bien qu est devenu pilote pour faire et
venez de son père un problème c'est que
mon père était déjà mort depuis quelques
années donc je suis devenu magicien
quelque part ce n'est pas loin de mon
père marini tout le long de sa cavale il
s'appelle bruno après je veux dire
pendant l'âge qu'on de 16 à 18 ans oui
j'étais presque tous les soirs leur
garde à vue
oui là je vous parlais de l'hôpital
quand vous êtes en garde a nommé un
moment je commence à avoir ma photo dans
tous les commissariats et je commence à
me dire mais c'est pas bon ça ouais vous
disais c'est pas bon cette chaîne non
non non ce n'est pas pas du tout cherché
et déjà être pressée pas de fierté
gaulle et qu'elle se dit je suis fier
d'avoir été donnée je suis fier d'avoir
été en prison on n'y a pas de fierté
vous avez été la fiancée plupart des
gens voilà qui vous diraient oui ton
père tout d'abord dans tous les sens
ouais bah moi et vous avez toujours dix
ans élite et vous avez deux bidons oui
toujours
oui nous allons retirer des problèmes
non non non aujourd'hui une vie
tranquille vous vivez à côté de chez mon
père oui vous êtes tranquille et à une
embrouille et la toubib c'est ça
aujourd'hui vous êtes magiciens
ouais ouais pas aujourd'hui depuis 25
ans pensez que votre père aurait été
fier de vous je pense qu'il est fier de
moi
il est fier de vous serez venu voir vos
spectacles je pense qu'il a un regard de
la houe et ouais bah merci en tout cas
et je vais dire à mon père qui fasse
attention à tout inquiétez pas vous avez
bien où nous attend je m'occupe de tout
mon père c'est l'ennemi public numéro un
aux six ans o'neal à merci